gaming show the pc gaming show was going
to be a three this year I'm not really
sure what it is some part of a like a
three hour stream where the pc gamer
showing on current pc games throw up
close eee pc games what play games on
your pc.watch the pc game show so yeah
it's kind of we've got an actual like
official unofficial official home for pc
games at e3 we're gonna show off with pc
games we thought why not come in here I
talked about breathing let's do it what
do you think about pc games I like XCOM
ex-cons clean consoles no X come for you
yeah man we always coming to consoles
but the only announced it for pc who
knows maybe they're trying to angle for
us some time to exclusivity Council Sid
deals anyways probably uh yeah they
teased it and so we're gonna see it in
action I think we're gonna see babe
they've got their reveal well actually
they didn't tease anything about like to
knit on pc game day for pc footage but
yeah yeah more XCOM good it would not be
surprised to see one of those pop up on
maybe when so near nintendo's conference
as a oh yo look we got on our console
two weeks before the other one that
would certainly you can see make this
teaser make a little more sense because
here they can get a little bit of the pc
only juice and then it at e3 so near
microsoft's can make a splash at their
press conference by having you know Jake
Salomon walk out and talk about XCOM you
know it's another pc game Kevin vinyl I
do rock so three yeah that's a pc game
um it is rumors yeah supposedly um I
don't know like I was saying this okay
Dark Souls obviously my favorite game
the outgoing Derek souls don't be sad
turns out the guy you made Dark Souls no
that's his ensure no that's Derek Derek
smarts brother right uh no I Dark Souls
my favorite game of the the last console
generation so I love dark souls
obviously dark souls 2 blood weren't all
these things i love but you know what i
worry that dark souls you know if the
dark souls 3 rumor is true i actually
think that it might it could potentially
be coming into like Assassin's Creed
territory oh yeah if from software is
not careful and
makes Dark Souls 3 different enough
because if this suddenly becomes like a
yearly thing to get a Dark Souls like I
don't want it to go into that category
as you know let's let's do something
really cool and different with Dark
Souls 3 yeah we got a bunch of
interesting games to talk about but
let's bring it over to the world of
hardware just for a second oculus we've
been seeing oculus at e3 for years and
years seems like this year they're
making a big push to show it off and two
people on the show floor onto various
press outlets as well Alexa you looking
forward to see more of this you think
we'll actually get like a firm release
date on yo this is what the oculus is
it'll be at this day go to your best buy
and pick it up so I think so personal
note on the oculus the last time I
played it I got very motion sick so i
will probably not be purchasing an
oculus effect I mean it's been years
Facebook the Facebook merger was flushed
yeah we have to get a release date or at
least a release window or something now
they should they have to start talking
it's been too long it was interesting at
GDC this year there was it was Villar
everywhere it was popular it was
Morpheus it was uh in videos making one
may be honored there was a osv are like
just tons and then the valve one with
HTC yeah it was all over the place and I
think that that enthusiasm has to spill
over into III somehow I feel like that's
sort of the harbinger of this is a III
where people really start talking about
VR in earnest with sort of release
windows with games associated with them
and I don't know Morpheus I feel like is
gonna have to feature in sony's press
conference for sure all right let's take
that V and flip it upside down and put a
little line across at AR about hololens
excited for that bad boy it's like VR
except if someone comes up and hits in
the face with a baseball bat you'll see
it come you shake it might look like a
giant fish but you know it's gonna come
at you yeah I would like to see some
more stuff along those lines but then
again it's you know I've played I've
used an oculus I've played that VR so I
have a solid reference point this the
hololens stuff I have not seen negatives
so it's just these concept videos for
now and I feel like in order for this to
like really either catch on or me to
just be like well this is crazy I'm
gonna have to actually try it seems
something that's so hard to just get
excited for looking at Chris it's going
to be exactly like that
that what you see there but that's
exactly what it's all going to be like I
just exactly that Microsoft are really
good at creating use case scenarios that
people can really empathize and connect
with knowing you're just at home with
your bike thinking about redesigning
yeah you know how you're an engineer and
like all walks of your life crotch
rocket was Green yeah Macario minecraft
all opinion I'm totally an architect so
this is all this is this is exactly what
I'm gonna do one or around my kitchen
fun stuff it's the future folks as
stepping away from this I have wonder if
that'll be like the connection like in
two years time we're like they were
filling this [ __ ] the whole time I
was under utilizing that in trying to
prepare my pipe and the just couldn't
even see the video that was projecting
on the bleach ball getting back to the
world of video games at Tacoma I have
Tacoma and adrift yeah written down here
beside each other because both these
games called nice little teasers short
teasers last year both of which were
very spacey let's go with Tacoma first
of all okay with this fulbright yeah
guys that made gone home they showed it
at the PlayStation no they should at The
Game Awards last year I'm fulbright will
actually be I think on stage they've
announced they're gonna be on stage at
the pc gaming show so i think we're
gonna see more of tacoma crossing my
fingers for hands on this looks super
cool like gone home in space yeah and
then another game in space kind of hot
off the heels of gravity it felt like
last year was adrift dread this is sort
of drifting into the excused upon an
oculus territory as well I know they've
been demoing an oculus as well I always
got the feeling just as with the pc
stuff that a lot of these games that
they're showing off on oculus are also
trying to take a swing at Sony maybe
because we'll hear more about Morpheus
perhaps but this game looks interesting
as well right yeah this is Adam Worth's
game oh cool the guy that like Microsoft
though you really got me where ya tweet
the wrong thing in the wrong place sure
did a bad tweeters making a game that's
what you're telling me yeah pretty much
game I've heard from they showed it at
an event I think during GDC and I was
not there but people that were there
told me that this game looks phenom
whole quote so I'm excited the next on
corporation are good friends publishing
everything online in China are going to
be there probably Alexa we're talking
earlier with
cliffie B's project project boss Rick's
Tree Project Blue Streak mr. eeka he's
gonna show off hella weird guns apparent
look it's kind of under the Toronto but
but not really it's got its got samurais
in it Hassan is also publishing a ton of
other stuff so could be this could be we
know cliff he will be there be there be
no they publish everything good who
knows every day they've shown they've
shown off this video which shows off a
fancy tree and some lighting in a very
first person shooter tech demo ii way
hopefully they actually show off once
you like game feel like it was a match
and tell us the real title of that game
yeah and hopefully it'll be arena
shooter it actually sticks this time
around and yeah so we know cliff is
gonna be there Dean holes gonna be there
as well Daisy Bohemia are gonna be there
so Pacific okay we can get over slowly
over Dean Hall last year when i
interviewed dino all he was like oh hi
dear might use III dirty has development
going on i want to know just climbed
Everest just find Everest a week earlier
[ __ ] crazy man can't wait to see what
Dean halls latest adventure was so do
you think he maybe Daisy coming to
consoles or something like Bohemia
they're terribly or they could be I
guess why would that be of the pc gaming
sure yeah I mean could be an expansion
could be they could be making another
game because they make Armas well yeah
to be something totally different and
they continue to just churn out the
Armas stuff like when nobody's watching
they're just like ARMA 3 miss ARMA 3
that or they're getting the developers
like put in prison just everywhere I
know right like you don't even hear it
anymore and let's talk about as star
citizen is going to be there as well
yeah it just keeps I think it's like
keep giving a millions of dollars even
million I think a moment is that and
have you seen have you actually seen
sort of a trailer or gameplay of this
that has gotten you excited and the
first person stuff that's leaked because
I know they had a massive leak there was
a Terran tech sorta got pulled off their
servers I think was two weeks ago and so
there has been like demos of the first
person stuff out there and I guess they
put at their own as well and I feel like
what they need to do take they obviously
have a mass movement of eyes on it but
to get like the sort of mainstream
gaming crowd involved but it is have a
game yeah it's a while they just need to
do like the kind of a this is what the
game is because at the moment it seems
like it's the
menagerie of sku's and like different
ways to buy in and different parts of
the game coming at different time in the
same way any dangerous is but just you
can go play any dangerous and play a lot
of it right now yeah they need that that
you know vertical slice or that turn
that net presentation were the sort of
direct line of experience of what can I
do in this game how am I seeing myself
there and you know it doesn't need to
say all the features it doesn't
encompass all the stretch goals and such
but but this is the game I when you show
it like that when you see someone that's
like that's the game I've always wanted
I mean I actually mentioned Derek smart
smart earlier we really weird but that's
like the kind of game that he was always
trying to do with battle cruiser and
anybody he was doing this a long time
ago now we're just doing that but like
an insanely you know beautiful you know
top you know top notch version of that
so but that's the game I want fly around
in space l'anima land on a planet shoot
some things do do do all of the things
we've got a bunch more games to talk
about here as some of which are new IP
but let's say let's take a minute to
talk about blizzards at they don't
usually go to e3 they don't have boots
they don't show things off they will be
having some sort of presence at this pc
gaming show what do you guys expect for
me i just want to see more overwatch
it's got to be over watch it's got to be
over watch and then here's a dislodge
hmm so maybe some changes maybe
expansions maybe whatever i don't know i
don't play MOBAs but probably overwatch
maybe a starcraft 2 expansion yeah
entertain the back seems to think we'll
have some more Diablo stuff out there
Kevin what do you think it out yeah I
mean it'll it's just gonna be I mean
it's blizzard it's gonna be a lot of the
things that we expect and that's gonna
be enough yeah do you think that they'll
go that's you mentioned so you on
overwatch norcraft Diablo heroes of the
storm that's four separate projects I
feel like bringing all of those four to
a pc gaming show might like you're
getting into host just host your own
thing territory blizzard and then I
wouldn't be surprised those only two or
three it's gonna be a lot more seems
like a bit of a stretch I feel like
overwatch has to be their focus because
it's going into open its going to beta
sometime this year well yeah I also
wonder if we're going to see dot pop up
on and one of the console manufacturer
shows as well we'll have to wait and see
and getting back into the pc stuff I'm
going to throw in a couple of names here
and see if any of these stick for you
because you got quite a lot and ccp are
going to be there eve online or you
think maybe they'll do something with
dust um dust is PlayStation exclusives
so probably not but I'm just ring if
they're going to show up a ps4 I'm
wondering if they're going to show
Valkyrie which is the oculus realm yeah
vr think so maybe we'll see more of that
more of that it seems like it's been a
bad for so long at this stage a soma so
much that's from frictional games are
the guys that made amnesia and penumbra
this is there like sort of space scary
game it went dark for almost a year and
now they're showing more teasers for it
so they said they'll be on stage so I
guess we'll see it there too as strafe
is going to be there which is a game we
had on the mix here that awesome little
party and Mary organized a couple of
months ago and it's that crazy kind of
quake doom weird like robach pixels and
like sprites shooter looking forward to
seeing more that that new doom looking
to new for you yeah right why don't you
bring it back to this guy helaas think
alex on my crop as well and creative
assembly gonna be there till a total war
is out now yeah i crossed out or
something so wonder what they're gonna
be show up me a total boy new expansion
packs and they're they're big on the
mobile stuff and on that like that right
now total war is just like a brand that
crosses platforms so probably lots of
that stuff wait and see add something
new and divergent like alien isolation
ya did oh yeah alien we sort of their
total war until they are what your this
is it yeah I came to do really well in
sales you would have thought but Sega
apparently not very happy with it
unfortunately add the witness are we
gonna get a release date for that thing
okay I forgot about that game pc and
playstation 4 yeah blow is a brilliant
puzzle designer but please just give me
that game I promise I won't be mad or
more and I bet it's I bet this fall it's
not at all Dana tentacle HD as well
maybe we might see some of that and no
man's sky people talk about when we get
the pc obviously it's been showing off a
lot a lot of the Sony conference and
it's kind of I don't think they've ever
made it official
Iseman or whether or not coming in on PC
chances are it's coming out on pc
afterwards finally to be awesome and I
don't know if they're gonna be on the
show at all but I do know that they're
in LA so hopefully get to see some more
that while we're there I'm not at the pc
gaming show there and sadly for everyone
else at dirty bombs they don't play
dirty bomb yeah played some dirty bomb
yeah like dirty bomb yeah it's kind of
cool yeah yeah it's it's like an open
beta so I mean you get to play it good
luck major bottom right now i think i'm
not exactly sure planetary bomb right
now as you as we speak what yeah yeah oh
man we gotta wrap this up what are games
that I don't mention here at killing
floor 2 that's that that's like out now
is no developer developers are they're
showing their wares maybe they're one of
the few games this happens every year
where a game is just come out and they
just just before e3 and they but they're
on the show floor still show it yeah
yeah yeah like it's a big show your game
is out of course you're gonna want to
get on that stage if you're that
developer hmm all the eyes of video game
demarre on III can't blame anyone for
wanting to get get a piece of that and
that's the pc gaming as we see it coming
up to e3 thanks very much for watching
it's like one long pc game wait a second
hot scoops Chris walk civilization
rising tide yes I do beyond Earth
experimental say you build some places
on the water gonna see it grad this here
yeah yeah coming out this fall so we'll
probably see some gameplay during
something it some part of e3 I think I
ought to be on the game spot stage I
don't know oh my gosh if only we knew if
only what is a document we could just
put up on the screen just for a sec yeah
and we'll have all at pc games and more
on the game spot stage in fact III is
just gamespot all that week our homepage
is basically we used to make an e3 hub
it's now just on gamespot com so all the
e3 news all the presentations all the
live shows that we have our stage of
course kind of funny stage at gamespot
all that good stuff is going to be
available on cakes Wacom's what do you
have to type that in do people type that
into the browser's anymore it's not a
thing that happens at people to bookmark
it already have I just hit GA and then
and it should hopefully get to gamespot
hope that it's not where it goes when I
type hey soft love you got it yeah love
it all right we're done today Mary Kay
and dime ahora Josh Shaw Air tay
everyone in the back thanks so much for
the producing this week's show we will
be back on gamespot com next week when I
talk on the lobby about Sony we're gonna
talk I think about EA Ubisoft and Square
Enix Square Enix I see you then take
care